tristan thompson wants khloe kardashian
back it is what it is while the two are
successfully co-parenting their
three-year-old daughter true a source
tells e.t that tristan wants to be more
than just co-parents quote tristan is
still very flirty with chloe and tries
to get her back but chloe's focus is 100
percent on true right now and showing
true that they can co-parent in a
healthy way while also ensuring that she
always feels very loved and supported
the source adds that chloe still makes
sure to include the 30 year old
basketball player in dinners outings and
play dates with true so they can have
time together as a family i don't think
there needs to be negativity on anywhere
back in june chloe and tristan split
after new cheating allegations surfaced
against the pro athlete who was the
subject of similar scandals in the past
at the time a source told dt that the
pair is done romantically after chloe
gave tristan several chances when you're
on this journey it is you have to be
really vulnerable and it's
emotional and
really really hard the source adds that
the constant cheating rumors were hard
for coco to hear and they ultimately
decided to end the relationship for
chloe's mental health i'm just super
happy and content and i'm focused on
work and like taking care of me my body
and soul and true as for coco's famous
family our source at the time explained
they thought her split from tristan was
good and healthy for her and if you
remember chloe addressed tristan's
infidelity at the keeping up with the
kardashians final season reunion special
which was filmed in april beanbag lover
tweeted chloe when tristan first cheated
on you how did you know
he it hadn't been done nor will be done
again well it was done again
it was done again i know the growth and
all the work that he's done i know all
the help that he's got and the constant
efforts that he makes every single day
and it really wasn't an easy thing for
him but i don't understand why someone
would go through all that if they
weren't really serious since splitting
chloe and tristan have seemingly
remained on good terms after all the
source added at the time that chloe just
wants her baby girl to have a good
relationship with her father
my daddy
what my daddy
yeah
but reconciliation rumors have been
running rampant last month chloe
addressed rumors that she and tristan
are a couple again on social media one
commenter retweeted a post about her
reportedly giving the boston celtics
player another chance and coco responded
you're telling me you made an assessment
about my life because of a random blog i
think that says more about you than it
does about me
so aggressive meanwhile tristan didn't
directly reply to the tweet but he said
this gossipers are worse than thieves
because they attempt to steal another
person's dignity honor credibility
and reputation which are difficult to
restore so remember this when your feet
slip you can restore your balance when
your tongue slips you cannot recover
your words act accordingly
[Music]
you